- Surpr--oh, it's just Brooke.
Hey, is Chasey
coming down soon?
'Cause I'm illegally parked.
- You got him a car?
- Yeah.
- He's 14.
- Hey, well, everybody's gonna
get him a car when he's 16.
- Oh, whoa, sick ride, baby.
- I got it for Chase.
I think he's wheely
gonna like it.
You know,
'cause of the wheels.
- [laughs]
- Hi, Lance.
This guy's with me,
Brooke Dubek.
- Sorry, you're not
on the list.
- Oh, family doesn't need
to be on the list.
I know that
'cause I made it.
- It doesn't matter.
If you're not on the list,
you have to go in standby.
- With the losers?
- [scoffs]
Thank you so much for coming.
- It's so good to see you.
You're so tan.
Did you go on vacation?
- Oh, no, I went on
"Watch What Happens Live."
- You did?
- Yeah.
It was stupid but,
you know, it was cool.
- God, this party's crazy.
Your brother's gotten so huge.
My students would die if they
knew I was here right now.
- I can get you a picture
with him if you want.
- Oh, um...
- Or with Esther Lay.
I just met her.
She's really, really nice.
I mean, it's weird that
she's here, but, you know,
it's helpful
to know people like that.
- Why, is she a director?
- No, she's a chip heiress.
- Oh.
- Supris--ah, damn it.
Hey, uh, is ChaseDreams
still up there?
Because I got him a present.
I think he's wheely gonna--
[horn honking]
Hey, go around.
Just go around me!
- Can't believe I'm in line for
a party that I planned.
- I know what
could cheer you up.
Check out my new shoes.
They're dry-erase, so you can
make 'em any kind you want:
Nike, Adidas, red.
Right now, they say,
"Happy birthday, Chase."
Actually, they say
"Hap irthda, Cha."
I ran here.
- Yeah, someone named
@CaryDreamsFeet started
following me, which is so weird
because my feet are fine.
- You should get
the foot filter app.
- Yeah, it really smooths out
your feet and toes for pics.
- Oh, that's a good idea.
- I'm Jeremy, by the way.
- Oh, sorry, that's Jeremy.
- [gasps]
Hi, you're Jeremy?
- Yes.
- Are you really gay?
- [gasps]
Cary, this is so good.
- Thanks, Mom.
- Mona, I wanna
go over there.
- Okay.
I love gay guys.
- So you been
DVRing "RHONY"?
- No, Lance, I'm
a businesswoman now,
so I don't have time for
"Real Housewives of New York."
- That's why I DVR.
- Okay, two more.
- Oh, thank God.
I have to pee so bad.
- Oh, ow.
Remember to send Chasey down.
I don't want him to forget
about me tonight.
Or whatever.
- Why is the women's line
so long?
It's like, use the men's.
That's what it's for.
See, totally empty.
[gasps]
Oh, Chase.
- Little man.
- [moans]
- God, he looks like shit.
Do you think
anyone saw him?
- No, we took him
out the back, B.
No one will ever
even know he left.
- Any minute now.
- This is ridiculous.
I was downstairs for 30 minutes
and he got this wasted?
You know, sometimes
I feel like I'm the only one
that's looking out for him.
- What about Care?
- I mean, yeah, he's great,
he's just--he's a little
orange right now.
- You mean like tan?
- No, like orange inside.
[both laugh]
I think he's just
going through something.
He's not the only one.
I didn't see my mom
once tonight.
Like, where the [bleep]
was she?
- Girl, you are
loving these nuts.
You mom is my friggin'
spirit animal right now.
- Very cool, Mona.
- Wait, I have to tell you
what happened this week.
I joined a gym,
as you can see,
and my first morning
on the treadmill,
one of my students
got on next to me.
- No.
- Yes.
I was too embarrassed
to let him see me run,
so I hid in the locker room
and watched clips of dogs
feeling guilty on my phone.
- The same thing
just happened to me.
I had to start working out
'cause I was on
"Watch What Happens Live."
- Yeah, you mentioned that.
- Yeah, I mean,
like, it was stupid,
but, you know, some people
said I was good on it.
- Well, I can't wait
to watch it.
- Oh, I could pull it
up right now.
- Oh, um...
- Just--yeah, I mean, just--
Just--yeah, okay,
here we go.
It's still loading.
Still loading.
I think
it's taking a long time
'cause I'm downloading
that foot filter app.
- I can't believe Chase's
first time getting drunk
was in a club.
I just wanted him to have
a typical teenage experience,
like mine.
- What was yours?
- I got wasted on a thing
of peach schnapps under my bed
and my mom found the bottle
and grounded me
and then I told her
I wished she was dead
and we didn't talk
for a month.
Chase'll never get that.
- What, don't worry,
cook Brooke,
he'll have plenty of firsts.
Maybe he'll lose his V-card
the way you did.
- To the drummer
from Snow Patrol?
Ew, Lance.
- [vomits]
- Ew, Chase.
[tires squeal]
- Out, everybody out.
- No, sir, we're about
to get on the bridge.
- I don't care.
Out!
- All right, it should
load better out here.
- Surpri--oh, God damn it.
- Streeter?
- God damn it.
- Did you get Chase a car?
- Yes, I got him a car,
and it's a great deal too.
He only has to say Chevy Camaro
in his next three songs.
- Uber for Jordan?
- Uh, what?
- Uber for Jordan.
I'm Jordan.
- This isn't an Uber.
- Sorry, I don't like it
when the drivers talk to me.
- Yeah, this is good.
You're cute.
- Yeah, thanks.
- Should we go back inside?
- Oh, no, was it--was it weird
that I made you watch that?
- Yes.
- Okay, uh, well,
we want to go back inside.
CaryDreams.
- You're not on the list.
- Try gay brother.